nous avons un rôle c'est faire rêver les
femmes et c'est aussi faire rêver les
hommes qui regardent
elle est une référence dans le monde de
la broderie de luxe et de la haute
couture la maison lesage
créée en 1924 par albert et marie-louise
lesage destiné à la haute couture
certaines pièces sont uniques en leur
genre en 1988
yves saint-laurent demandé à françois
lesage héritier de la maison de
fabriquer une veste en hommage à van
gogh
nous avons agrandi la reproduction du
tableau et après avoir agrandi ceci nous
avons fait il esquisse à peu près dans
le volume des cardigans nous avons
choisi notre palette de fournitures donc
oui il ya environ 450000 païenne pierre
balmain christian dior hubert de
givenchy ou encore jean louis scherrer
de nombreux au couturier ont collaboré
avec la maison lesage un bon grip au
moins est une chose qui fait toute mon
admiration et c'est ton travail de
collaboration entre le coach et des
moteurs qui a des roms
pensez si la broderie est la marque de
fabrique de la maison lesage
l'entreprise n'hésite pourtant pas à se
diversifier au début des années 90 elle
saisit l'air du temps avec la production
de pin's brodé pour le grand public la
joie c'est de pouvoir offrir un bijou
brodé le sage peut être porté par un
grand public alors que nous nos produits
sont quand même réservé à 10 ans une
élite extrêmement ut en 1992 françois
lesage décide de partager son savoir
faire une école est alors créée à paris
des stages sont même proposés chaque
année près de 400 élèves de tout âge
apprennent à broder je fais déjà de la
broderie par moi-même et j'aime le bien
donc mes enfants voulu me faire plaisir
au fond secours danser dans ce câble en
2002 chanel a racheté la maison lesage
depuis l'entreprise de broderie de luxe
continue d'être le fournisseur des
grands noms de la mode
[Musique]